What's up guys. I'm here with my boy, Cody. I'm Noel.
And we're here to answer the internet.
Step that one. Would you rather suck one here in the classic?
The classic male question.
Suck one Dick for 50 K or get 5k for every Dick. You suck.
well. No, no, no, no. Hold on. Hold on. Cause I'm thinking I could do like,
you can do 10. Think about 10 bucks. Now think about 10.
You know, who's the dude at the Nathan. [inaudible] all right.
Who's the dude does the,
like the professional Hoss hot dog guy.
Yeah. He could probably make a load of money doing this right here.
Um, man. Yeah, let's go with one singular one day. Singular.
Would you date a girl? Knowing all of her previous exes are dead. Yeah.
This is presidential
[inaudible] what? Why? Why are they dead? Those are. That good.
You just die instantly. Oh shoot.
This one weirds me out, man. Did she kill them or did she just like date?
Super old dudes. Oh, I mean, it could be, it could be harmless.
It could be that she's a black widow. Yeah. It's like the movie teeth.
You got nothing to worry about though.
For her like gone back to her exits right now or everything. Don't worry about.
I would do it. I like danger. She's like Kurt Cobain of vagina. All right.
Um,
would you rather orgasm every time you hear all star by smash mouth or hear star
every time you orgasm? I think that the same thing,
hearing it every time will be sick. Yeah. You know, it's coming.
It's like inception, like music starts playing. Uh
huh. Yeah. I think hearing it is good. Uh,
would you rather lose a leg or never have sex again? that leg.
Yeah. Well easy. I only need one. Look at that.
Boom problem. No problem. I got a sexy, full mango. Yeah.
Give me a peg leg. That is cold as.
If you could fight one person to the death and switch lives with them.
If you win, who would you fight it? Jeff Bezos.
I was going to say Jason, stay in them, but yeah. All right, man.
I'll kill that nerd and be a billionaire.
Would you rather have your mom send you a nude or send all your friends and nude
friends? I'd send all my friends. My mom, my mom's name.
Check my mom. Uh, who's the one cartoon character. You would bang,
dude. Lowest Griffin. Yeah. You see? No.
[inaudible] what came to mind. Watching the Andrew Nick video.
That was fast as hell, man. You didn't even skip a beat. Whose one? Cartoon.
Lois Griffin. Yeah, man. I was watching porn on the way over here.
Lola bunny. I dunno. Every time you laugh, a dog dies.
Or every time you fall in love, there's a genocide shoot.
Who's getting genocided though. All right.
We don't want you guys getting canceled. Let's cut this one, man.
Killing so many dogs today.
Would you rather have hot dogs for fingers or hamburgers or butt cheeks?
That's tough, man. That's tough. I'd say burger cheeks,
burger cheeks. Yeah. Burger cheese, grease up the toilet seat.
How long would it take you to eat a whole lot? I could do it like, yeah,
you can do it in 10 minutes. 10 minutes. Probably two years.
Would you rather a goat and nobody knows or you don't it go.
But everybody thinks you did. Oh. Think it.
You know what I'm saying? Because you could deny forever. Yeah.
That's that's like some, like I went to prison for life, but I'm innocent.
You know what I'm saying? You know,
deep in your court to be still in prison for life. I know,
but at least you have the truth. You know what I'm saying? Nah, I'd that guy.
Sorry about getting canceled animal abuser right here.
Yeah, sure. A good time.
If you're a girl where one mascot had during sex for the rest of your life,
which one would you choose? Bruh Packers. Yeah.
Are you going to be in trouble for that one?
So you want me to look like Lois Griffin? Um,
I'll put the packer cheese head on her.
You meet your girlfriend's father for the first time. He hands you,
the ox score. What's the first song you played. Andrea Gummo
Andrea chestnuts of Snapchat.
[inaudible] you won't believe what she does. Yeah.
Yeah.